你想要问我的问题是你是不是恋爱脑？
那我明确告诉你是。
他去年工作调动，
一方面是因为他原单位比较特殊，
他整个队伍都是某关身份，
工作内容就是高强度的训练，
很封闭，
晋升也很受限，
另一方面就是当时的本意是想在本市内调动一个离我家比较近的单位，
最后是因为阴差阳错没调成，
退而求其次选择了隔壁城市啊，
因为我的户口在那边，
虽然不同城，
但是通勤比较方便，
然后我的工作呢，
又比较自由嘛，
就像去到那边也是一样，
可以带学生，
长远来看，
比留在本市未来的生活压力也会小很多。
在此期间，
我们跟各自的父母都沟通过，
都是没有意见的，
他原单位和新单位我都去住过很多次，
就是了解的人应该都清楚，
如果不是真正要结婚的对象，
基本不会带到单位去的，
他有了想要进一步发展，
就是过年的奇迹跟家长的计划，
那一切都是很正常的，
他父母临时变卦不同意的想法，
他本人也是前一天晚上才接受到，
他也很努力的争取了，
没有痛哭哭流涕，
据理力争，
然后也一直跟我道歉呀什么的，
他跟父母闹的也很凶，
他父母那一次当天就直接回老家了，
他之所以面对我逃避，
不跟我说。
真实的原因其实是怕伤害到我的自尊心，
因为他知道我性格很要强，
他觉得很愧疚又难以启齿，
有习惯性的顺从嘛，
因为从小到大没有无理，
我面对这样的突发情况，
他就不知道怎么应对，
我当时是很崩溃的，
也觉得他就是没有那么喜欢。
后来是从他姐那儿得知了真实情况，
我其实是决定放下了，
因为我不想让他为难嘛，
但对于我而言，
我是接受不了这种断崖式的分开，
后来我提出做朋友，
只是想给自己留一个缓冲的机会，
但是毕竟两个人还是有感情嘛，
下了面就是会情不自禁一来二去的就留在一起了，
只是两个人都没有明确的在提出复合的话，
就大家说白嫖也好，
或者有不合也罢，
我觉得就是心甘情愿的吧，
就是你俩男未婚女未嫁，
你俩在一起愿意有亲密的，
这个行为不违背道德，
也什么都不违背啊，
对于你自己的这个人生规划来说的话，
那现在啊，
男方的父母有动摇吗？
男方那边也没有说跟你复合，
也没有说推动婚姻啊，
就是现在处于这样一个人生阶段，
你自己能不能接纳，
如果说你自己说我很爱他，
我愿意接纳，
哪怕将来我跟他没有婚姻，
但是我。
我依然是愿意跟他保持这样的亲密关系，
就哪怕你持有这样的观点，
企实你自己是自洽的，
对，
从我这个角度来说的话，
尊重你自己的这样一个选择。
现在的问题是，
第一个是因为之前他父母知道你存在的，
他父母是没有阻止的，
他父母突然不同意的原因是什么？
然后这个原因有没有可能他父母那里会松绑，
会接纳，
明白吗？
这个原因我们后来就是有剖析过嘛，
自己是本着就是是缓则圆的这种原则嘛，
嗯，
就是因为问题确实是摆在这儿，
然后短时间内呢，
我也不太想逼着他去怎么样，
现在是觉得有希望能改变的，
这个有希望能改变主要是你男朋友去推动这个希望呢，
还是你在推动这个希望，
就说是你男朋友在不断的去再去影响他的父母，
去跟他父母去讲你有多好，
然后多么想跟你在一起，
还是你在推动这个希望我没有推动，
我们俩现在联系就是不是我主动，
就是一直是他在联系我，
然后包括他姐姐也是一直就主动找我呀，
跟我聊天呀，
然后约我见面呀什么的，
那你希望我会律师帮你分析的问题是什么呢？
在一起之后，
因为。
经历了这些事儿之后，
两个人就是褪去了恋爱时候的那种激情跟甜蜜，
现在反而就是相处的更真实，
是自己彼此内心最阴暗最龌龊的一面展露给彼此。
他对我现在也是无话不谈，
事无巨细的状态，
我们的感情就是不减反增了吧。
我们后来也剖析出他爸爸的那个不同意的原因，
就是早些年比较得意的时候残存下来的那些虚荣心，
在过年的时候，
第一次到他们单位就享受了各种权力优待，
之后就突然爆棚，
然后就深化了他自己本身对体制内的那种执念，
也就可能觉得他儿子前途无量吧，
觉得就可以找个更好的呀，
工作更体面的呀，
我认为是无可厚非的，
不认同，
但是理解。
后来事实证明，
这个男生他的工作经历跟他的性格并不适合现在的岗位，
他对于这种复杂的人际关系的处理常常是力不从心的，
以他自己的想法，
未来他大概率可能会转到技术教研岗，
就是安安稳稳的过日子，
爸爸就是都不配为在帮家产的这些事儿，
这个事儿他男生也是最近才逐渐了解到的，
因为他从上大学开始就没管家里要过钱，
然后就对家里的这个。
的经济情况他也一直都不知情，
包括他姐之前出国留学的时候，
他爸爸给了30万，
他姐回来的时候原封不动的又还给他爸了，
然后之前我们提到买房的时候，
他一直以为家里是能拿出150~200左右，
结果他爸就一直推脱，
到现在就一分钱没拿出来，
然后房子至今也没有买，
从过年到现在就这一年之间，
他们家里的关系就是已经有了很微妙的转变吧，
他爸也从之前在整个大家族里的一言堂到现在话语权慢慢的就被削弱掉了。
那综上所述啊，
我就想问您几个问题，
第一个就是结合这些客观实实来看，
您觉得我现在还是恋爱脑上头自己拎不清的状态吗？
如果是的话，
我希望您能点醒我，
如果不是，
您觉得这个男生还有可继续相处的必要吗？
从我的这个角度来看啊，
不是说我上一次劝你们分手，
我这一次就必须要劝你们分手，
才能够维持我的尊严，
或者维持我的权威性，
我还是要从你的实际出发，
从你的利益最大化出发，
来帮你来看待这个问题。
哦，
你自己呢，
是，
嗯，
31岁对吧？
对，
嗯，
然后你自己呢，
是有一份很好的工作，
我感觉你也很热爱，
虽然不是吃公家饭，
虽然不是体制内，
但这个工作收入还很稳定。
如过啊，
本人工作能力也很强的话，
你也是属于一个就是自己有一份自己喜欢且自己能够做得很好的工作，
然后也能攒固定的这个收入，
你就自己的生活是能过得很好的这样一个状态，
现在就是说这个男生的态度非常的关键，
这个男生在跟你分手的时候，
他不管嘴上说的再好，
嗯，
怕伤你的自尊心啊，
或者怎么怎么样，
但他那个分手的方式真的伤害了你，
断芽式分手的这个方式对你的打击是很大的，
这是客观的，
对不对？
我认为如果他是一个真的那么优秀，
那么成熟的一个男生，
在和你都已经谈婚论嫁这个阶段，
突然他爸妈不同意了，
突然他要跟你分手了，
我认为这个事情他首先应该考虑的是这件事情对你会带来什么样的心理伤害，
应该怎么做能够减轻你的心理伤害，
这是一个成熟的男人最起码应该考虑的是，
其实当时他没有就是很明确的说分手，
我果还原一下当时那个情况，
他本来都约好了要跟他爸妈去见一面，
都以临时通知你没有不见了，
说他要出差，
或者他有什么任务，
他有什么工作，
所以这个见面就取消了，
临时取消这个见面之后，
你俩就基本上就是很少联系了，
他也没有告诉你，
后来我生气，
他不。
他怎么跟我解释，
我有的时候会比较要强吧，
他一说不见面，
我就瞬间理解了嘛，
他就觉得他没法跟我交代，
因为他前一天晚上跟他爸妈吵完之后，
他大半夜给我发了很多信息，
就说什么哎，
我对不起你啊，
怎么怎么样，
因为我当时不知道那是什么情况嘛，
所以我的态度就很强势，
很坚决，
我就说那个啊，
你自己想好就行。
后来第二天没见，
是我跟他说，
我说那我没事，
就这样了嘛，
然后他就回了一个嗯嗯，
从那个嗯之后呢，
后来我就给他打电话，
然后他就一直在哭，
我问他什么他也没说，
然后我就知道什么意思了，
我就挂了电话，
后来就没有再联系他了，
大概断联系断了多久了？
嗯，
昨天大概断了有一周多，
他姐联系跟我，
我跟他姐联系了，
他姐我们两个就见了面，
然后他就大概跟我讲了一下他们发生没事儿啊什么的，
然后后来他又主动来找你呢，
还是你主动找他呢，
他找我，
他回来之后就见面嘛，
然后见面我们俩就聊了很多，
聊完之后，
因为我也不想让他为难，
说那那就算了吧，
那毕竟有感情嘛，
我说也不要说老四不相往来呀，
有什么就做朋友吧，
我俩就一来而去的，
就就在一起了，
就现在你们在一起有亲密的关系，
但。
是呢，
他也对外不再承认，
对他爸爸妈妈也不再承认你们是男女朋友的关系，
他也不对你进行任何的许诺，
也不再说我一定会说服我爸爸妈妈的，
我还是会娶你的，
我还是要跟你在一起的，
也没有这样的表述，
是这样吧，
嗯，
他没有主动说，
但是上次他爸打电话问他，
因为他姐一直知道我们在联系嘛，
那你们是不是还在联系？
然后他当时就怼了他爸，
说他联系了又能怎么样，
人家现在早就看不上我了，
然后后来他爸一直没再说什么，
我觉得这个事情哦，
你现在最好的姿势是什么啊？
最好的姿势是你也急驴找骂，
既然你不承认我是你女朋友，
既然你不推进我们的婚姻，
既然你现在对我是这样一个状态的话，
那我认为我是有权利骑驴找马的，
我，
我不是你女朋友，
我说白了，
咱俩现在不就是约着内角吗？
就这么一种关系吗？
你也不承认你是我男朋友，
那要是我觉得对于你来说最舒服的姿势就应该是骑驴找骂的姿势，
也一心想着想嫁到他们家去，
这就是知他我自己也有接触过啊，
多接触啊，
她要问你的话，
相亲看电影了，
他要问的话啊，
我们出去旅行了，
你别说你是跟男的还是跟女的，
就算你是跟女的，
你也说啊，
我们一起看电影了，
他问是男的是女的，
你就不回答，
你也跟他说，
包括他那段时间，
他领导给。
介绍啊什么的，
他也会跟我说，
我也会跟他说，
那就比呗，
比是找个更好呗，
也没有比吧，
就两个人都觉得，
哎，
可能也是没有找到更好的吧，
但是我觉得我之前聊的或者接触的，
嗯，
条件啊什么的，
肯定比他还要好一点，
就是自己心里过不了那个坎儿，
因为毕竟跟他还没有完全断干净，
接触之后你就会有对比，
会有一些生理上的排斥。
我觉得你想要问我的问题是，
你是不是恋爱脑，
那我明确告诉你，
是你在这段关系当中的话，
你被人家牵着鼻子跑，
你给他打个电话，
你觉得他在哭，
你就心软了，
他哭是因为他自己没能力，
他自己不敢反抗，
他自己又给不到你一个好的结果，
你心什么软呢？
你应该哭才对啊，
你不觉得吗？
他凭什么哭呀？
是，
是母亲吗？
是恋爱的，
现在这个状态与你而言的话，
你要是想过得更好的话，
你就得骑驴找马，
你就得找个好的，
是吧？
你跟这个男的在一起，
我说句难听点的话，
你换个思维想，
反正老娘也不用对你负责任，
老娘也不用给你生孩子，
老娘也不用养着你的，
你拥有了他的青春可以了啊，
尝一口可以了，
也没有说非他不可，
包括这今天了，
姐呢，
她家里这个情况可能我自己。
在纠结嘛，
嗯，
他家里条件也不咋地啊，
对，
也就那样，
就是好色，
就是跟他在一起亲密关系太和谐了，
你不舍得这一口跟女人过日子啊，
就亲密关系这个事儿是重要，
但是还是她的性格秉性，
能不能够跟你共同去组建一个能够抵御风险的这样一个家庭，
这个事儿更重要，
我觉得我们俩已经到这一步了，
就是最差的结果可以预见到了，
你如果现在再去找一个新的，
就会有新的矛盾或者新的问题，
错了，
姐妹，
你预见的最差的结果是你嫁进他们家，
然后跟他爸关系也不好，
这是你预料到的最差的结果，
对不对？
错了还有一种结果就是他死活就是不会跟你领结婚证的，
他会用各种方法搪塞你，
可能可能跟他再混个两年三年，
他还是不娶你，
跟孩子也好，
组建家庭也好，
你就错过了你的黄金的时期了，
这是最差的结果，
我现在如果要跟他就是完全断开，
是不是需要我逼他一把？
你如果真的很想嫁给他的话，
会有一条路，
或许是一条出路，
就是你正儿八经找个男朋友，
她那头她急眼了，
她也找不到更好的了，
她只能找你，
你天天发朋友圈，
警察可见啊，
只有这条路，
她有可能急眼，
他有可能急眼，
他只是跟你领个结婚证，
但你。
你跟他过日子的话，
也未必好过姐妹啊，
只能说完成了你的一个心愿啊，
但结了婚跟这样的男的，
他自己内心深处他都没有那种独立性，
他连他父亲都不敢反抗，
你跟他在一起的话，
以后这个家就得靠你了啊，
如果我真的找了的话，
他就不会找我了，
那你不找他也不找你啊，
他也不跟你结婚啊，
所以您觉得他就是还是不行，
不靠谱，
他没有那么的爱你，
他对你的这份爱不足以抵抗你们结婚之后的风雨，
不足以抵抗来自父母的也好，
来自各方面的这个也好，
不足以抵抗这个风雨啊。
那我最送一个问题就是，
如果我们俩现在就是分开了，
所以我如果不跟他分开，
我不会想找下一个嘛，
跟他分开了，
那我以后嗯应该怎么调整自己，
在未来的这种择偶上怎么选择，
怎么把握呢？
有没有什么建议？
就是以后你找对象，
你只要记住一条，
对于你来说幸福指数就有大范围的提升。
千万不要拿你将来的老公的缺点弱点去跟你的前男友的优点去比，
只拿你将来丈夫的优点去跟你前男友的弱点去比。
我举个例子，
将来千万不要觉得哎呀，
我老公没有前男友帅，
没有前男友。
个子高，
不要比这个就比我老公有担当，
敢于在我的面前去维护我，
就敢于为自己做决定啊，
我老公是属于这样的，
你明白吗？
如果我们的女人啊，
学会这一点的话，
我们的幸福指数上涨最起码30%的点，
就是永远不会拿我的老公的弱点去比我前男友的优点，
我只拿我老公的优点去比我前男友的缺点，
我这日子老好过了，
嗯，
明没有，
就这样啊，
他真的没有那么喜欢咱们，
要么就是他没有这个能力去那么喜欢咱们，
这两件事儿虽然说不一样，
但结果都是一样的，
结果就是你跟他过日子挺累。
我再说一遍啊，
这个总结出来挺经典的，
他今天遇到的这个男人非常的典型，
典型的点就在于这样的男人，
他要么是没有那么喜欢咱，
所以他没有必要为了咱们去跟他的父母去对抗，
没有必要为了咱们去改变他的生活轨迹，
改变他自己未来的规划，
那他心里是想跟咱在一起的，
但他没有这个能力去对抗，
没有这个能力去坚持他自己。
我跟你说，
跟这样的男的过日子也过不好，
你们同意吗？
就是典型的不主动，
不负责，
不拒绝，
而你，
你想跟我好，
你想跟我去开放什么的，
我奉陪到底啊。
但我对你我也没有承诺，
他给自己找的道德上的依据是什么？
我没有承诺过要娶你啊，
你自己心甘情愿跑来找我的呀，
我没有承诺一定要给你一个结婚证啊，
我都明说了呀，
对吧？
我不能给你婚姻啊，
你非得来找我呀，
难道我还能拒绝你吗？